SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLY. DODD. DURAZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. CIERTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER WILK
. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS. BEYOND
THE RAILING. PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED TONIGHT BY. BY WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER BY OUR
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH, PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU. LET US GATHER IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. SPIRIT OF GOD,
GIVER OF LIFE. AS YOU CARE FOR
ALL CREATION, GIVE US YOUR
PEACE. MAY OUR SECURITY COME NOT
FROM WEAPONS, BUT FROM RESPECT.
MAY OUR STRENGTH COME NOT FROM
VIOLENCE, BUT FROM LOVE. MAY OUR
OWN WEALTH COME NOT FROM MONEY,
BUT FROM SHARING. MAY OUR PATH
BE NOT ONE OF AMBITION, BUT OF
JUSTICE. MAY OUR VICTORY BE ONE
OF FORGIVENESS. SO THAT UNARMED
AND CONFIDENT WE WILL BE MOVED
AND COMMITTED TO DEFEND THE
DIGNITY OF ALL PEOPLES. ON
BEHALF OF ALL CREATION, MAY WE
SHARE TODAY AND ALWAYS THE BREAD
OF SOLIDARITY AND PEACE. AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WELCOME TO OUR NIGHT SESSION,
SENATORS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE ONE
OF OUR SENATORS WHO JUST EARLIER
TODAY EARNED CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHEST HONOR, WHERE SHE WAS
AWARDED THE ORDER OF CALIFORNIA
AWARD. SENATOR SUSAN EGGMAN FOR
HER TENURE AND HER ADVOCACY. IF
WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WERE
DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. HERE WE GO. OUR BREAD
AND BUTTER. CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH 20 ON THE SECOND READING
FILE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 846 WITH
AMENDMENTS 2023, WITH AMENDMENTS
2579, WITH AMENDMENTS 1854 1982
2521. SECOND READING FILE WILL
BE DEEMED READ. SENATORS, WE ARE
STARTING WITH SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER ONE. THAT'S GOING TO BE
ITEMS 191, 192, 193, 196, 197,
198, 199, 200 AND 201. SENATOR
WIENER IS PREPARED FOR ALL ITEMS
AND WILL KICK US OFF WITH ITEM
191. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 160 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACT RELATING TO THE MEDICAL
MEDI-CAL AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU MAY BEGIN. I THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
THIS IS THE FIRST IN A SERIES OF
BILLS THAT WILL BE TAKING UP
THIS EVENING AS PART OF THE 2024
2025 BUDGET PACKAGE. BEFORE WE
GET TO THE FIRST BILL, I JUST
WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS ON THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT. THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT INCLUDES $293 BILLION
IN TOTAL SPENDING, OF WHICH
211.5 BILLION IS GENERAL FUND.
THE BUDGET IS BALANCED IN BOTH
2024 2025 AND THE 20 2526 FISCAL
YEARS AND INCLUDES OVER $46.8
BILLION IN SOLUTIONS IN 20 2425,
DUE TO MORE THAN A DECADE OF
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING AND
RESERVE POLICIES, AND DESPITE
THE CHALLENGES OF THE CURRENT
BUDGET, THE STATE WILL MAINTAIN
A $22.2 BILLION COMBINED RESERVE
FOR FUTURE YEARS. HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE INCLUDE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR K THROUGH
14 SCHOOLS, IF THE BILL THE
BUDGET FUNDS PROP 98, AT $1.9
BILLION ABOVE THE MAY REVISION
AND A DEPOSIT OF $1.1 BILLION
INTO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT, THE
BUDGET RESTORES PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS TO CORE PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING CALWORKS FOSTER CARE
AND IN-HOME SUPPORT SERVICES. IT
RETAINS OVER 11,000 ALREADY
AWARDED ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS AND REDUCES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONE YEAR DELAY FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES TO A SIX MONTH DELAY.
IT MAINTAINS FUNDING FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION, AND IT REDUCES
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION BUDGET BY
APPROXIMATELY $750 MILLION. IT
PROTECTS MANY CLIMATE RELATED
PRIORITIES, SUCH AS OFFSHORE
WIND BUILDING, DECARBONIZATION
AND ENERGY RELIABILITY PROGRAMS.
IT REJECTS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO PERMANENTLY
ELIMINATE OVER 2.4 BILLION IN
ANNUAL NEW HEALTH CARE
INVESTMENTS SCHEDULED TO TAKE
EFFECT NEXT JANUARY, AND IT
PROVIDES $1 BILLION FOR THE
HOMELESS, HOUSING AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. ROUND SIX. THIS IS A
BUDGET DEAL ENCOMPASSED BY ALL
OF THE BILLS THAT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON TONIGHT, OF WHICH WE
CAN BE PROUD, AND IT INCLUDES
REAL AND LASTING SOLUTIONS TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET THROUGH 20
2526, WHILE PROTECTING THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE TO CORE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND SO THE FIRST
BILL THAT WE ARE VOTING ON
TONIGHT, IS AB 160, WHICH IS THE
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION TAX
TRAILER BILL, THE BILL INCREASES
THE TAX ON MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS TO DRAW DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL REVENUE AND
ACHIEVES OFFSETTING SAVINGS TO
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND BASED
ON UPDATED FEDERAL GUIDANCE, THE
BILL INCREASES THE PER ENROLLEE
TAX ON MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO ACHIEVE THE MAXIMUM
BENEFIT TO THE STATE ALLOWABLE
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS
MODIFICATION TO THE MCO TAX WILL
RESULT IN AN ADDITIONAL NET
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT OF
APPROXIMATELY $1.77 BILLION IN
THE COMING FISCAL YEAR AND 1.92
BILLION IN THE FOLLOWING FISCAL
YEAR, FOLLOWED BY 1.44 BILLION
IN 2026 2027. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. RIGHT NOW I'M LOOKING
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FOR
ITEM 191 AB 160. I'M SEEING
SENATOR O'NEILL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'LL JUST MAKE SOME
OVERALL COMMENTS, AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
DID, I DO NOT INTEND TO SPEAK ON
EVERY BILL. WE HAD A ROBUST
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING EARLIER
TODAY AND HAD LOTS OF GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT. BUT LET
ME JUST STRESS, THIS IS THE
MAJORITY PARTY'S BUDGET. AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE, I
LEARNED OF THIS DEAL ON A
TWITTER POST. EXCUSE ME ON X,
FORMERLY KNOWN AS TWITTER POST.
OVER THE WEEKEND, I WAS NOT
PROVIDED ANY DETAILS BY THE
MAJORITY PARTY, OF THE BUDGET
DEAL THAT THE PRO TEM, THE
SPEAKER AND THE GOVERNOR HAD
WORKED OUT. AND AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE, BECAUSE OF THAT, THIS
BUDGET CERTAINLY REFLECTS
PRIORITIES. AS MY FRIEND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO SAID. BUT IT
IGNORES PRIORITIES OF 8 MILLION
RESIDENTS OF THIS STATE, BECAUSE
NONE OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
WERE INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE BUDGET. SURE, WE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT AS WE DID IN COMMITTEE
TODAY, BUT NOT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF IT NOW. AGAIN, MY FRIEND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TALKED ABOUT A
DECADE OF RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING.
IF WE HAD A DECADE OF
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING, WE MIGHT
NOT HAVE HAD THE SIGNIFICANT
DEFICIT THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR. AND
IT'S EASY TO SAY THAT PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE OF, DYNAMICS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. BUT WE
HAD A COUPLE OF YEARS OF
UNSUSTAINABLE INCREASE IN
REVENUE, AND IT COULD HAVE BEEN
EASY ENOUGH TO RECOGNIZE THAT
UNSUSTAINABLE INCREASE. INDEED,
THE GOVERNOR HAS LABELED IT AS
SUCH SINCE. AND IF MORE MONEY
HAD BEEN DEPOSITED TO THE
RESERVES, WE WOULD BE IN A MUCH
BETTER POSITION NOW. BUT WE
STUCK TO THE CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED MINIMUM DEFICIT. AND AS
I'VE SAID BEFORE, THE BALANCE
THE BUDGET IS BALANCED NOMINALLY
, BUT IT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE. I
KNOW YOU WILL HEAR DIFFERENT
FROM THE OTHER SIDE, BUT YOU CAN
MARK MY WORD. WHEN THE GOVERNOR
GOES TO INTRODUCE HIS JANUARY
25TH JANUARY PROPOSAL IN 2025,
HE WILL BE DEALING WITH A HIGHER
DEFICIT THAN WE ARE THINKING OF
NOW. I THINK WE'RE ASSUMING
WE'RE RUNNING INTO MAYBE A $10
BILLION PROBLEM IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR. IT WILL BE HIGHER
THAN THAT. WE ARE FORECASTING
TOO MUCH MONEY IN REVENUE,
SIGNIFICANTLY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HIGHER THAN THE ALLEGE
ANALYST, OTHER DETAILS OF THIS
BUDGET, AS I SAY, ARE THAT MAKE
IT NOT SUSTAINABLE. I'VE
DISCUSSED THAT BEFORE. I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT, BUT I JUST
WANT TO STRESS THIS IS THE
MAJORITY PARTY'S BUDGET, NOT A
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET. SENATOR
HEALEY, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AS SOMEONE
WHO IS HIGHLY CRITICAL OF TAXES,
I WANT TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THIS BILL, I DO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL 160, WHICH WOULD GENERATE
NEW FUNDS THROUGH SELF-IMPOSED
TAX ON HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THIS
IS NOT A TAX ON THE PEOPLE. IT
WOULD HELP TO MAINTAIN AND GROW
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE. IT
WOULD ALSO MAKE CRITICAL
ADVANCEMENTS TO ACCESS AND
QUALITY CARE, ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
SENATE-DISTRICT. FOR THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR DALY, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I AM DID NOT
SPEAK TODAY IN BUDGET, AND I'M
ONLY GOING TO SPEAK HOPEFULLY
ONCE TONIGHT. SO I'M GOING TO
USE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT ALL THE BUDGET BILLS AND
THE BUDGET IN GENERAL. SO THIS
IS THE 12TH BUDGET FOR MY TEN
YEAR AND MY LAST. I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE THAT JUST GOT AN
ESTEEMED AWARD IS HER LAST
BUDGET AS WELL, BUT I WANT TO
JUST START BY MAYBE GIVING YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY OF, WHY I
CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE. I CAME
BECAUSE IN 1929, MY GRANDFATHER
CAME TO CALIFORNIA DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION, A REAL
DEPRESSION WHERE PEOPLE WERE
STANDING IN LINE LOOKING FOR
FOOD AND LOOKING FOR A JOB. HE
CAME FROM IDAHO. HE WAS ONE OF
12 KIDS AND LOOKED FOR A JOB. HE
COULDN'T FIND ANY WORK IN LOS
ANGELES, BUT HE ENDED UP UP
NORTH AND FOUND OUT THAT IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY THEY WERE GIVING
OUT LAND GRANTS TO VETERANS, AND
HE PUT HIS NAME IN A PICKLE JAR,
AND THEY DREW HIS NAME OUT, AND
HE GOT AN 80 ACRE HOMESTEAD IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY IN TULARE LAKE,
CALIFORNIA. HE PAID HIS TAXES
FOR FIVE YEARS. HE BUILT A ONE
ROOM HOUSE ON THERE AND MOVED
HIS FAMILY FROM IDAHO OUT TO
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT STARTED THE
DAWLEY FARM 94 YEARS AGO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, A SMALL BUSINESS,
AND WITH HIS SEVEN KIDS, HE WAS
MY DAD WAS THE YOUNGEST OF THE
SEVEN, WAS ABLE TO PICK UP SOME
LAND IN LASSEN COUNTY, WHERE MY
WIFE AND I WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO BUY THAT FROM MY MOM AND DAD
AND I RUN THAT SMALL BUSINESS
TODAY. IT'S A GENERATIONAL
THING. IT'S A FARM THAT IS
ORGANIC. THERE'S A FARM THAT IS
DEALING WITH A LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY, I
SHARED WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
THAT CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE TO NO
OTHER PLACE. IT IS THE GREATEST
PLACE ON THE PLANET. AND WHY IS
THAT? BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
PACIFIC OCEAN. WE HAVE THE
SIERRAS, THE STORMS COME IN. IT
DUMPED SNOW IN THE SIERRAS. WE
HAVE THE FERTILE VALLEY SOILS.
IT'S THE GREATEST FARMING PLACE
IN THE WORLD, AND WE HAVE THE
GREATEST PEOPLE. WE HAVE
ENTREPRENEURS AND WE HAVE THE
GOLD RUSH. AND WE HAVE MOVIES,
AND WE HAVE THE TECH INDUSTRY.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN JUST WHAT
THE GOVERNOR SAID IN HIS STATE
OF THE STATE LAST NIGHT ABOUT
HOW GREAT CALIFORNIA IT IS,
GREAT. BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES AS A SMALL
BUSINESS. THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IN THIS BUDGET
MEMBERS, IF YOU'RE A CONVENIENCE
STORE OWNER OR YOU'RE A
LANDSCAPE COMPANY OR YOU'RE A
SALON OWNER, OR YOU'RE A FAMILY
FARM OR A SMALL BUSINESS LIKE ME
, YOU'RE YOU'RE FACED WITH A LOT
OF REALLY TOUGH CHALLENGES. WE
HAD THE 60 HOUR WORK WEEK FOR
AGRICULTURE WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THEY PASSED A LAW THAT
SAID WE COULD NOT USE THAT
ANYMORE, AND I WAS CALLED A
SLAVE OWNER BECAUSE I HAVE FARM
WORKERS ON MY FARM. THERE ARE NO
SLAVES IN CALIFORNIA. YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO LEAVE YOUR JOB
ANYTIME. AND I WANT TO THANK MY
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE AWESOME, WHO
WORK FOR ME. I HAVE SOME OF YOU
IN BUSINESS. YOU HAVE TO KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE GREAT
EMPLOYEES. YOU'RE ONLY AS GOOD
AS YOUR EMPLOYEES ARE. BUT THIS
LEGISLATURE TENDS TO GET IN
BETWEEN ME AND MY EMPLOYEES A
LOT. SO I WANT TO GIVE THAT MY
TALK ON THE SMALL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE BEING
AFFECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE. I
WATCHED THE STATE OF THE STATE
LAST NIGHT, AND THE GOVERNOR
SAID THAT IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE
IN HIS THE POLICIES THAT HE PUTS
OUT, THAT YOU'RE A HATER OF
CALIFORNIA. THE WORD HATE WAS IN
HIS SPEECH. I ACTUALLY PRINTED
IT OFF AND HIGHLIGHTED IT IN MY
HOME WHEN I WAS GROWING UP. WE
COULDN'T USE THAT WORD HATE
BECAUSE HATE IS A STRONG WORD,
AND I DON'T ALLOW MY KIDS TO USE
THAT WORD BECAUSE IT IS REALLY
STRONG. AND SO I TAKE OFFENSE TO
SOMEBODY CALLING SOMEBODY ELSE
HATEFUL WHEN THEY JUST DISAGREE
WITH SOME POLICIES. NOW, I'D
LIKE TO TALK TO THE BUDGET AND
WHAT IT HAPPENS TO DO TO MY
SMALL BUSINESS DURING THE COVID
CRISIS, CALIFORNIA GAVE
UNEMPLOYMENT OUT, AND
UNEMPLOYMENT IS PAID INTO BY
EMPLOYERS FOR THE WORKERS. SO
WHEN THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED, THEY
ACTUALLY GET UNEMPLOYMENT. BUT
CALIFORNIA DIDN'T DO A VERY GOOD
JOB. THEY HAD PROBLEMS IN 2008
WHEN WE HAD THE FIRST CRISIS,
BUT WE DIDN'T FIX THOSE CRISES,
AND WE PUT OUT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO PEOPLE IN PRISON AND
PEOPLE FRAUDULENTLY GOT 18 TO
$20 BILLION WORTH OF WORTH OF,
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THEY
DIDN'T PAY YOU THIS BUDGET DOES
ONE THING. IT PAYS THE INTEREST
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE WE BORROWED THAT MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
ALL OF US WHO HAVE EMPLOYEES,
WHICH I KNOW THERE ARE TWO OF AT
LEAST ON THIS FLOOR. I KNOW MY
GOOD FRIEND OF MY LEFT HERE HAS
EMPLOYEES AND I HAVE EMPLOYEES.
WE WE'RE GOING TO PAY THAT DEBT
BACK. WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T GIVE
THE MONEY TO PEOPLE IN JAIL. WE
DIDN'T CAUSE THE PROBLEM. THAT'S
SOMETHING I HATE. I HATE TO HAVE
TO PAY FOR SOMETHING THAT I
DIDN'T DO. THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED A $20 MINIMUM WAGE FOR
FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS. AND YOU
MAY WONDER WHY. HOW DOES THAT
IMPACT MY LOCAL FARM? WELL,
BECAUSE IT SETS THE BAR AT $20.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO WORK FOR
15 OR $18 AN HOUR WHEN YOU CAN
WORK FOR 20 AT A FAST FOOD
RESTAURANT? SO IT MOVES IT UP
FOR EVERYBODY. THAT IMPACTS
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BUDGET ALSO TAKES AWAY THE
NET OPERATING LOSS, REALLY
CRITICAL FOR AGRICULTURE. WHY
BECAUSE WE HAVE SWINGS WHEN THE
RAINS COME OR DON'T COME, AND
WHEN THE COMMODITY MARKETS ARE
UP AND DOWN, SOME YEARS WE MAKE,
SOME YEARS WE DON'T. AND WE'RE
ABLE TO SMOOTH THAT NET
OPERATING LOSS OVER TIME. THAT'S
A DEDUCTION THAT I DON'T HAVE
NOW. SO IT'S A TAX ON MY
BUSINESS. TO THE TUNE OF $15
BILLION. IT'S GOING TO COST
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD REGULATING AND FORCING
BUSINESSES TO TRANSITION TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TAXES FEES
INSURANCE LIABILITY REPORTING
AND JUST GENERAL COST. AND I
BROUGHT UP MEMBERS IN THE LAST
TIME WHEN WE DID THE TWO PARTY
DEAL ABOUT THE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE LEAVING CALIFORNIA. SEE, I'M
NOT GOING TO LEAVE EVEN NO
MATTER HOW HARD IT IS TO RUN A
BUSINESS HERE. MY GRANDFATHER
GOT A PIECE OF LAND. I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN A
WONDERFUL ONE OF THE GREATEST
STATES IN THE NATION. AND I'M
NOT GOING TO LEAVE MY KIDS ON
THE HOOK, NOR YOURS. THE NEXT
GENERATION NEEDS SOME STABILITY
WHEN IT COMES TO BUSINESS.
BUSINESSES PAY THE TAXES BEFORE
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING ELSE IN
GOVERNMENT. I LOVE CALIFORNIA
AND I JUST WOULD HOPE THAT
SOMEDAY THIS LEGISLATURE WOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE OUT
THERE, WE'RE STRUGGLING. WE
DON'T HAVE A GIANT LOBBY TO
LOBBY. WE'RE NOT UNIONIZED. WE
DON'T NOBODY REALLY REPRESENTS
ME IN THIS LEGISLATURE BUT ME. I
HEAR FROM MY NEIGHBORS ALL THE
TIME. THEY JUST WANT TO STAY ON
THEIR FARMS. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY, YOU KNOW, IN CLOSING, THAT
I'VE BEEN TRIED TO ALWAYS TRY TO
TALK TO THE ISSUES AND NEVER
MAKE IT PERSONAL TO I. IT WAS
ONE OF MY GOALS. IS TO SHARE THE
STORY, BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IT'S JUST WHAT WE HEARD
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN. POLITICS IS ABOUT
RELATIONSHIPS. SO THIS IS MY
LAST BUDGET, AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT I AM STANDING
UP AND I AM PUSHING BACK.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I HATE
CALIFORNIA OR THAT I'M SLAMMING
CALIFORNIA. IT MEANS THAT I WANT
TO STAY HERE AND I WANT THE
NEXT. MY KIDS, YOUR KIDS AND THE
NEXT GENERATION TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT SMALL
BUSINESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
I JUST WANT TO CLOSE WITH
SAYING, CUT US SOME SLACK, HELP
US OUT. REGULATIONS AND THE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HURT AND IT HURTS
THE NEXT GENERATION. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE
VOTING. I'M GOING TO BE VOTING
NO ON MOST OF THESE BUDGETS. BUT
THERE IS A COUPLE I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR. BUT I JUST WANT TO. I
WANT TO TELL THE STORY BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS AN AWESOME STATE.
WE JUST NEED TO WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
BUSINESSES, BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
BACKBONE AND THE SMALL BUSINESS
ESPECIALLY. THANK YOU, MEMBERS
FOR ENDURING THIS TALK WITH ME.
AND IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
ON 12 BUDGETS WITH YOU OVER THE
TIME. THANK YOU. SENATOR DOLLY.
SEEING NO OTHER DISCUSSION,
SENATOR WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I WILL JUST
POINT OUT THAT, WELL FUNDED
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES,
FOSTER CARE, IN-HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES, AND GREAT
WELL-INVESTED TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS BENEFIT BOTH DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARO. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NÓ DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN MAGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OKUBO.
NO. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
PORTANTINO AYES 31. EIGHT. NOES.
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 182 AB 161. SENATOR
WIENER, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 161 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET, AN
ACT RELATING TO HUMAN SERVICES
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER. AYE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 161 IS THE HUMAN
SERVICES TRAILER BILL. IT ENACTS
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT TO
IMPLEMENT A PERMANENT FOSTER
CARE RATE STRUCTURE EFFECTIVE
JULY 1ST, 2027. FOSTER CARE
PAYMENTS WILL BE BASED ON THE
CHILD'S NEEDS AND FOLLOW THE
CHILD, NOT THE PLACEMENT. THIS
INCLUDES FUNDING THAT WILL ALLOW
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE TO
PARTICIPATE IN EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES IN THE CALFRESH
PROGRAM, THE BILL ESTABLISHES
THE STATE EMERGENCY FOOD BANK
RESERVE, EXTENDS THE CALFRESH
SAFE DRINKING WATER PILOT
PROGRAM, AND CODIFIES FEDERAL
RULES ABOUT REPLACING STOLEN
FOOD BENEFITS AND THE CALWORKS
PROGRAM. THE BILL IMPLEMENTS THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT TO HOLD
INTENSIVE CASEWORKER HOURS FLAT,
REQUIRES REPORTING ON THE
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM,
AND REQUIRES THE STATE TO APPLY
FOR A NEW FEDERAL PILOT
OPPORTUNITY TO MEASURE OUTCOMES
OF FAMILY WELL-BEING. THE BILL
ALSO MAKES OTHER CONFORMING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO ALIGN WITH
THE HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? I'M
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ALVARADO
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NEELO. AYE
OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. RATH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYES 39.
NØ ZERO. MEASURE. PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM 193. AB 162.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 162 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET, AN ACT
RELATING TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB 162 IS
A DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TRAILER
BILL. IT ENACTS THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT TO MOVE THE FINAL
PHASE OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
RATE REFORM TO JANUARY. FIRST,
2025. IT CODIFIES THE MASTER
PLAN FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
AND REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE MASTER
PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS. IT EXTENDS
THE OPTION FOR FAMILIES SERVED
BY REGIONAL CENTERS TO HOLD
THEIR INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN
MEETINGS REMOTELY, SUBJECT TO
ADDITIONAL MEETING PARAMETERS.
IT ALLOWS INFANTS AND TODDLERS
RECEIVING EARLY INTERVENTION TO
BE CONCURRENTLY ASSESSED FOR
PROVISIONAL ELIGIBILITY FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES. IT
REQUIRES. REGIONAL CENTERS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO SOCIAL
RECREATION. IT REPEALS REGIONAL
CENTER FAMILY FEES AND MAKES
OTHER TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
COLLEAGUES. WE'RE GETTING A
LITTLE TOO LOUD. A LITTLE TOO
LOUD. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL, AB 162, I REALIZE
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS A
NEGOTIATION WHEN YOU COME TO A
BUDGET PERIOD, AND I REALIZE
IT'S ONLY BETWEEN THE, THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE ONE PARTY IN
THIS HOUSE AND ONE PARTY IN THE
OTHER HOUSE AND THE GOVERNOR.
BUT THERE'S NO WAY. WE SHOULD
NEGOTIATE THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED, BENEFITS OR THEIR RATE
INCREASES, IT WAS SAID TODAY IN
COMMITTEE, THEY WERE LIKE,
THEY'RE COUNTING DOWN THE DAYS,
RIGHT? WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET THAT RATE INCREASE SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THESE SERVICES TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY, AND THEN WE JUST RIP IT
OUT FROM UNDERNEATH IT. OR YOU
GUYS JUST RIP IT OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THEM BECAUSE IT'S NOT
IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT, THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS WE COULD CUT THIS
BUDGET. IT WAS NOT A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY COMPARED TO SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
FUNDED IN THIS BUDGET. AND, SO
AND I KNOW THE BUDGET SUB THREE
CHAIR FOUGHT REALLY, REALLY
HARD. AND SHE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THERE'S NEGOTIATIONS THAT HAVE
TO TAKE PLACE. BUT THE
VOLATILITY THAT WE HAVE PLACED
ON THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS
OF OUR SOCIETY THAT ARE THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED OR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS IS JUST HEART
WRENCHING. AND TO SEE THEM COME
IN AND ADVOCATE FOR THINGS THAT
MAKE THEIR LIFE BETTER AND MAKE
THEIR LIFE MORE WHOLE, THAT THE
STATE SHOULD PROVIDE TO THEM, BE
RIPPED OUT FROM UNDERNEATH. AND,
THERE ARE, LIKE I SAID, A FEW
GOOD THINGS IN THIS BILL, LIKE
THE BUDGET CHAIR SAID, BUT I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BALANCE
THIS BUDGET ON THE BACKS OF
THOSE THAT ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NÓ. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
NO LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NEILA.
NO. OKUBO. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. RATH. AYE. RUBIO.
ACIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WHEN.
AYES 31. NOES ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO. ITEM 186,
AB 166. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
NØ. IT WAS EYES 31 NOES! SEVEN.
YES. MEASURE PASSES. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 196 AB
166.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 166 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE ON BUDGET,
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB 166 IS
THE HOUSING TRAILER BILL, THIS
BUDGET REFLECTS A RECOGNITION OF
TWO FUNDAMENTAL FACTS ABOUT
STATE ØNDING ON
FIRST, THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
CONTINUES. SO THIS BUDGET, LIKE
THE LAST THREE BUDGETS, INCLUDES
$1 BILLION FOR THE HOMELESS,
HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION, OR HAP PROGRAM, AS
WELL AS NEW INVESTMENTS IN
ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION. SECOND,
OF COURSE, NO AMOUNT OF MONEY
WILL BE ENOUGH TO ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS IF IT IS NOT SPENT
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
ACCORDINGLY, THE TRAILER BILL
BEFORE YOU INCLUDES NOT JUST
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW
STATE DOLLARS ARE SPENT, BUT
ALSO NEW MECHANISMS FOR TRACKING
PERFORMANCE AND REQUIRING
IMPROVEMENT. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL BEFORE YOU LIMITS THE
AMOUNT THAT HCD MAY TAKE FROM
PROPOSITION ONE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO 3% OF
THE BOND PROCEEDS ALLOCATED TO
HCD PROGRAMS, IT DIRECTS THE
HOUSING AND FINANCE AGENCY TO
DEVELOP OPTIONS FOR THE FUTURE
OF THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR ALL
SHARED APPRECIATION LOAN
PROGRAM, AND IT PROVIDES
DIRECTION TO HCD ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE REGIONAL EARLY ACTION
PLANNING GRANTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR,
WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AS
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
CONTINUES TO GROW, YET WE
CONTINUE TO PUT MORE MONEY AT A
PROBLEM THAT WE JUST CAN'T SEEM
TO BE ABLE TO GET A HANDLE ON.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO ADD HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, BILLIONS
OF MORE DOLLARS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY SPENT OVER $24 BILLION
IN LAST SEVERAL YEARS, BUT YET
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY TANGIBLE
RESULT. AND ALL WE'VE SEEN
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GROW.
THERE'S MORE AND MORE TENTS IN
FRONT OF SCHOOLS, MORE AND MORE
TENTS IN FRONT OF PARKS. MORE
PEOPLE ARE LIVING ON THEIR
STREETS. MORE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
IN THEIR CARS. IT'S
HEARTBREAKING. AND THE
DESPERATION FROM FROM THESE
INDIVIDUALS. WE NEED TO HELP
THEM AND WE NEED TO FIND A WAY
THAT IS ACTUALLY TANGIBLE. IF WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP ON THROWING
MONEY IN TO A SYSTEM THAT ISN'T
WORKING, WHEN DO WE STOP? WHEN
WILL WE SAY, WAIT A MINUTE, THAT
PROGRAM IS NOT WORKING. LET'S
FIND SOMETHING ELSE. IF THERE'S
A PROGRAM THAT WORKS, LET'S PUT
MORE MONEY INTO IT. BUT IF IT'S
NOT WORKING, IT'S TIME TO PULL
THE PLUG AND FIND A RESULT
BECAUSE WE OWE IT TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS. THEY NEED TO BE
HOUSED. THEY NEED THE HELP AND
WE NEED TO HELP THEM. A RECENT
RELEASE REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT THE
STATE HAS FAILED TO TRACK OR
REPORT THE FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. THIS
AUDIT CONTINUES CONFIRMS THAT
WHAT WE KNOW WE'RE THROWING
MONEY AT A PROBLEM, BUT WE ARE
NOT SEEING THE RESULTS AND WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THE COUNTIES OR THE CITIES. THIS
BILL DOESN'T CREATE POLICIES TO
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
JURISDICTIONS WHO ARE MAKING
THESE PROGRESS. THERE ARE NO
METRICS AND NO WAY TO MEASURE
TRUE SUCCESS. FOR ME, TRUE
SUCCESS IS WHEN WE SEE LESS
PEOPLE ON THE STREET, WHEN WE IN
EACH OF US, DRIVE IN OUR
DISTRICT LESS PEOPLE ON THE
STREET, LESS TENTS AROUND.
THAT'S WHEN I BELIEVE IT IS
WORKING WITH THAT. FOR THAT, I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TO. WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
SOLUTION, A SOLUTION TO PUT
MONEY INTO SOMEWHERE THAT WILL
WORK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NØ. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
AYE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN NILO. NO.
OCHOA PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. AYE WILK. NÓ.
SCOTT. ABSENT. MEMBERS GROVE.
NO. WHEN OCHOA. BOGH PORTANTINO.
UMBERG AYE. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. WHEN OCHOA. EBCLC.
PORTANTINO AYES 31. NO SIX
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FIRE. TÂM 197. AB 168.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 168 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET. AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATORS
GETTING LOUD AGAIN. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB 168 IS
THE PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL.
THE BILL STABILIZES FUNDING FOR
THE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE GRANT. IT
CLARIFIES PROCESSES AROUND
RECORD RELIEF AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
REMOVES OBSOLETE REFERENCES TO
CLOSED PRISONS, AND MAKES OTHER
STATUTORY CHANGES NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET ACT. I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE, SENATOR WAHAB,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
GIVE ME TWO SECONDS. SORRY. SHE
RECOGNIZED. GIVE ME TWO SECONDS.
I SAID TWO SECONDS. ALL RIGHT.
SO, MORE SPECIFICALLY, DO YOU
HAVE THE TALKING POINTS AS CHAIR
OF PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET SUB FIVE
AND CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POLICY COMMITTEE, I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE INVESTED IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
COMPLAINTS OF STAFF AND SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT WITHIN OUR PRISONS.
WE ARE ALSO FOCUSED ON CLOSING
THE LOOP BY INVESTING IN REENTRY
SERVICES, SPECIFICALLY SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT AND MEDICAL
CARE, SO THAT PEOPLE RETURNING
HOME FROM PRISON HAVE HIGHER
SUCCESS RATES AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO COMMIT NEW CRIMES. WE
ALSO MAINTAIN $85 MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO COMBAT
RETAIL THEFT, IN ADDITION TO
PROTECTING FUNDING FOR STATEWIDE
ENFORCEMENT AND COORDINATION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. WHILE
OUR GOAL IS TO INVEST IN
PROGRAMS THAT PREVENT CRIMES
FROM OCCURRING IN THE FIRST
PLACE, WE ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
ADDRESS CRIME, AS IT HAPPENS,
TEN YEARS AGO, CDCR'S BUDGET WAS
$9.3 BILLION WITH A POPULATION
OVER 135,000. TODAY, CDCR'S
BUDGET IS 15 BILLION, WITH A
POPULATION OF AROUND 92,000, AND
THIS POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
CONTINUE TO DROP BY 86,000 BY
2028. THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION IN REGARDS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WHAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS DOING, BUT I
WANT TO BE VERY SPECIFIC. WE ARE
HOLDING THE LINE IN REGARDS TO
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY EFFORTS, MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BUDGET
MAINTAINS OVER $150 MILLION IN
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF
CRIME IN LIGHT OF A FEDERAL
REDUCTION. WE HAVE STEPPED IN TO
FILL THE GAP BY INVESTING OVER
$103 MILLION. LET ME SAY THAT
ONE MORE TIME. $103 MILLION TO
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS RAPID
REHOUSING AND CRISIS CENTERS AND
RESPONSE FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
OTHER CRIME VICTIMS. WE HAVE
ALSO MAINTAINED $50 MILLION FOR
FLEXIBLE ASSISTANCE TO
SURVIVORS. WE HAVE MAINTAINED
OUR COMMON SENSE BUDGET
INVESTMENTS AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE
BY PRESERVING FIREARM
RELINQUISHMENT PROGRAMS IN OUR
COURTS IN ORDER TO DISARM
INDIVIDUALS WHO POSE A DANGER TO
THOSE AROUND THEM. CONSISTENT
WITH LAST WEEK'S UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT DECISION. BECAUSE
WE KNOW THE PRESENCE OF A
FIREARM IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION INCREASES THE RISK OF
HOMICIDE BY 500. WE HAVE
INVESTED IN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS COMPLAINTS AGAIN
ABOUT STAFF, AND WE ARE ALSO
FOCUSED ON DOING MUCH MORE. AND
ALL OF THIS TAKEN TOGETHER,
THESE INVESTMENTS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, REENTRY SERVICES,
GUN VIOLENCE REDUCTION AND
SUPPORT OF SURVIVORS IS EXACTLY
WHAT PUBLIC SAFETY MEANS. A
COMPREHENSIVE AND BALANCED
APPROACH TO PUBLIC SAFETY, ONE
THAT INCLUDES BOTH PREVENTION
AND ENFORCEMENT. AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET PACKAGE.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SENATOR WIENER, YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI NØ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO
OCHOA. NO. BADIA AYE.
PORTANTINO. RATH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MIN. AYE
PORTANTINO. WILK NO. AYES 31
NOES EIGHT. MEASURE PASSES. NOW
ON FILE ITEM 198 AB 169.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 169 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET. AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, AB 169 IS
THE PUBLIC SAFETY JUVENILE
JUSTICE TRAILER BILL. THE BILL
MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES REFLECTING
THE CLOSURE OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND THE
REALIGNMENT OF JUVENILE
SUPERVISION TO THE COUNTIES,
INCLUDING IMPLEMENTING A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT TO SHIFT
ALL JUVENILE JUSTICE GRANTS FROM
THE BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION,
REQUIRING COUNTIES TO REPORT
SPECIFIED JUVENILE DATA AND
MAKING OTHER STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET ACT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SEE NO
MICROPHONE'S UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DAWLEY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMON
AYE. MAGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
NHIÀU OKUBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE AYE.
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DOLLY GROVE. JONES
NGUYEN. NILO PORTANTINO. SATO
WILK. AYES 32. NO. ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES FOR ITEM 199. AB 170 IS
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 170 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET, AN
ACT RELATING TO COURTS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, THE SHOW IS STILL YOURS.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, AB 170 IS THE
COURT'S TRAILER BILL. THE BILL
ENABLES THE HABEAS HABEAS CORPUS
RESOURCE CENTER TO PROVIDE
CONTINUING REPRESENTATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SENTENCED TO
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE. IT EXTENDS
SPECIFIED REMOTE COURT
PROCEEDINGS UNTIL JANUARY 1ST,
2027 AND MAKES OTHER STATUTORY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET ACT AND SUPPORT THE
OPERATIONS OF THE COURT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DEL. NÓ. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO. OCHOA
NO. PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. ACIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE GROVE. JONES
GROVE. NO. JONES. NO PORTANTINO.
AYES 31. NOES EIGHT. MEASURE.
PASSES. FILE ITEM 200 WERE ON AB
171. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 171 BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, YOU MAY PROCEED. I THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, AB 171 IS THE LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT TRAILER BILL. IT
REVISES TIMELINES FOR THE
EXPENDITURE AND OBLIGATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST
PROGRAM ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS. IT STREAMLINES PROCESSES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
STAFFING EMERGENCIES THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN CHALLENGES TO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF STATE LABOR LAWS.
AND IT INCLUDES $337 MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR A PROP
TWO SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
THAT WILL GO TOWARDS THE STATE'S
UNFUNDED LIABILITY TO CALPERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SEE NO MICROPHONES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE
JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN.
AYE. MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NØ. OCHOA. BOGH NO.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. RATH.
AYE RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
NØ. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROVE MCGUIRE. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYES 31. NO SEVEN.
MEASURE PASSES. THE LAST ITEM ON
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. NUMBER
ONE IS FILE ITEM 201 AB 173.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 173 BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION, AND
MAKE AN APPROPRIATION,
THEREFORE, TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER. AYE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB 173 IS THE
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL. IT
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING GRADE SEPARATION
PROJECTS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
AWARDED FUNDING IN EXISTING
STATE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
IT CLARIFIES THE STATUTES
CONCERNING THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY, INCLUDING
SPECIFYING THE IG'S DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES REGARDING
CONTRACTORS AND DEFINING, QUOTE
UNQUOTE DEFINING, QUOTE UNQUOTE
PERSONNEL ISSUES. IT REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
TO ANNUALLY REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PURCHASES, OWNS, OR
LEASES, AND IT REVISES THE
DETERMINATIONS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY MUST MAKE IN
ORDER TO REQUEST AN EBONY ALERT,
AND SPECIFIES THAT CHP'S ROLE IN
ASSISTING AGENCIES AND
ACTIVATING THE ALERT. I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I'M SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I,
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI NØ. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. GROVE. NO HURTADO. AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MINH AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NO. NILO. NO. OKOBO NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. AYES
31. NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS,
SENATORS. THE GOOD NEWS IS WE
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT. WE HAVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE READY TO GO.
THE BAD NEWS IS YOU GET NO
BREAK. SO WE'RE PUSHING THROUGH
SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
TWO ARE GOING TO BE FILE. ITEMS
2042052062072082092 10 TO 11 AND
212 WE'RE GOING TO START OFF TO
A FORCE IN OUR WIENER DRINK SOME
WATER. YOU READY? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ.
FOUND. ITEM 204. YEAH SLIDE IT
THROUGH. SENATE BILL 108 BY
SENATOR WIENER. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE BUDGET AND MAKE AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 108 IS
THE BUDGET BILL, JR, WHICH
AMENDS AB 107 THAT WE RECENTLY
PASSED TO REFLECT THE FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR, AS
I DESCRIBED EARLIER IN THE
PRESENTATION, THIS, BUDGET IS A
BALANCED BUDGET THAT, PROTECTS
SO MANY OF THE PRIORITIES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 108. WE
OFTEN SAY OUR BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND OUR
PRIORITIES. AND CONVERSELY, IF
SOMETHING IS LEFT OUT OF THE
BUDGET, THEN IT DOESN'T EXIST.
OR DOES IT EVEN REALLY MATTER?
THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB 108, BECAUSE IT
INCLUDES IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR
REPARATIONS. WE ARE THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO TAKE SUCH
BOLD ACTION. THOUGH THE 12
MILLION DOESN'T EVEN COME CLOSE
TO ADDRESSING THE HARMS OF
SLAVERY, IT IS AN EARNEST START,
AND WE HAVE TO APPLAUD AND
RECOGNIZE THAT ALTHOUGH MORE WAS
WANTED AND WILL BE NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE, I'M DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE
OF THIS INITIAL INVESTMENT. EVEN
IN THESE TOUGH FISCAL TIMES.
THIS FUNDING IS A CLEAR
REFLECTION OF OUR PRIORITIES AND
VALUES AS A STATE. THIS MONEY
WILL START TO STAND UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PAY FOR FUTURE
REPARATIONS. WE, AS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS, CONTINUE TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT THE HARMS OF SLAVERY
AND RACIST PUBLIC POLICIES ARE
NOT HEALED. THEY EXIST TODAY AND
IMPACT US ON A DAILY BASIS. WE
SEE IT ALL AROUND US IN LOWER
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES, EDUCATIONAL
UNDERACHIEVEMENT, HEALTH
DISPARITIES, AND SIGNIFICANT
WEALTH GAP. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR LEGISLATORS,
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS, AND THE
GOVERNOR TO IMPLEMENT
REPARATIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN, THIS BUDGET REFLECTS THAT
REPARATIONS DO MATTER AND WILL
BE A PRIORITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS YEAR AND
GOING FORWARD, THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING. I URGE I VOTE,
SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR. FRIENDS, I JUST WANTED TO
RISE AS CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB TWO
TO TALK FOR A FEW MINUTES. ABOUT
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACHIEVE AND MAINTAIN
WITH THIS BUDGET. THIS IS MY
FOURTH YEAR HERE. OF COURSE,
THIS IS THE MOST DIFFICULT
BUDGET. AND AS LONG AS WE'RE
RELIANT ON INCOME TAX AND
CAPITAL GAINS, UNLIKE OTHER
STATES, WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE FLUCTUATIONS. I'M JUST
REALLY PROUD OF, OUR SENATE, LED
BY OUR PT AND OUR BUDGET CHAIR
FOR THE WORK THAT WE DID, I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT A FEW THINGS. YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE THOUGHT WE WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE A STEP BACK ON
CLIMATE, BUT WITH THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, I WANTED TO JUST SHARE A
FEW PIECES OF INFORMATION.
NUMBER ONE, CLEAN ENERGY
EXCEEDED 100% OF DEMAND IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY FOR 69 DAYS IN
A ROW. THIS YEAR. IT WAS ONLY A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE DID THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME. WE DID 69
DAYS IN A ROW. WE'VE INCREASED
CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES
PROCUREMENT, INCREASED GRID
RELIABILITY, AND WE HAVE SHRUNK
THE PROBABILITY OF BLACKOUTS.
WE'VE INCREASED BATTERY STORAGE
BY 1,200% SINCE I'VE STARTED
THAT TO OVER 10,000MW. BY MY
CALCULATION, THAT'S MORE THAN
THE TEN NEXT LARGEST STATES
COMBINED IN TERMS OF BATTERY
STORAGE. WE'VE DOUBLED THE SALE
OF NEW ZERO EMISSION MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. WE'VE
EXCEEDED 100,000 PUBLIC CHARGERS
AND 500,000 AT HOME CHARGERS.
WE'VE CONSERVED OR RESTORED
NEARLY 1 MILLION ACRES OF
NATURAL LAND AND INCREASED URBAN
TREE CANOPIES BY 200,000 TREES.
THIS BUDGET CONTAINS $30 MILLION
FOR FIRST IN THE NATION. AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT SYSTEM, SO WE
WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER TARGET
WHERE WE NEED TO BE PROTECTING,
PROTECTING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. COMMUNITIES IT PROTECTS
SMALL FARMS. WE RESTORED MONEY
FOR A SMALL FARM PROGRAM AND
ALSO PROTECTS OUR AG ECOSYSTEM
WITH MONEY PROTECTING FROM
INVASIVE FRUIT FLIES OR OTHER
CLIMATE EMERGENCIES BY RESTORING
17 MILLION AND EXPANDING PROGRAM
RELIEF FOR ALL CLIMATE IMPACTS.
I WANTED TO TALK FOR A MOMENT
ABOUT WILDFIRE BECAUSE THIS YEAR
WE REALLY BUILT ON THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT WE'VE
HAD AROUND PREVENTION STARTED BY
MY PREDECESSOR, SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI, REALLY FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION AND THEN EARLY
DETECTION AND SUPPRESSION. WE'VE
BUILT THE LARGEST AERIAL
FIREFIGHTING FORCE IN THE WORLD,
69 VEHICLES ABLE TO RESPOND TO
ANY WILDFIRE WITHIN 20 MINUTES.
THAT'S WHY EVEN THOUGH WE
ACTUALLY HAD MORE FIRES THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, WE ACTUALLY GOT
TO THEM EARLIER AND WERE ABLE TO
PUT THEM OUT EARLIER WITH
OBVIOUSLY MUCH LESS DAMAGE.
WE'VE ALLOCATED OVER 3.7 BILLION
FOR FOREST TREATMENT TO REDUCE
HAZARDOUS FUELS. AND THIS YEAR
WE FINALLY REDUCED THE CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTER WORKWEEK TO 66
HOURS. FOR THIS BUDGET, INVEST
IN NOVEL TECHNOLOGIES, INCLUDING
LIDAR TECHNOLOGY OUT OF SCRIPPS
AND UCSD TO FINISH MAPPING OUR
FORESTS. THAT WILL REALLY HELP
US GOING FORWARD. AND AGAIN,
THIS IS PART OF, I THINK, OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN, AND WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THAT PAYOFF,
ALTHOUGH WE'RE STILL, OF COURSE,
GOING TO HAVE A FEW DIFFICULT
YEARS AHEAD. I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE ONE LAST PIECE ABOUT AREA,
NOT IN SUB TWO, BUT JUST
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO THINK
ABOUT HOW DOES THIS WHAT WE DO
HERE AFFECT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
BACK AT HOME AND THERE'S A WOMAN
I KNOW I SERVED ON THE CHILD
CARE PARTNERSHIPS COUNCIL IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY, AND I CHECK IN
WITH HER EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE.
SHE RUNS A LARGE STATE
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM IN MY
DISTRICT, AND WHILE WE DIDN'T GO
AS FAR ON SLOTS, CERTAINLY AS WE
WANTED IN CHILD CARE, I CHECKED
WITH HER BECAUSE WHEN I STARTED
IN 21, HER TEACHERS WERE MAKING
1750 AN HOUR AND PROBABLY ONE OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE AREAS OF THE
STATE, 1750 AN HOUR. AND AFTER
WHAT WE DID IN RATE REFORM, MY
VERY FIRST YEAR, I CHECKED WITH
HER AFTER THAT YEAR, AND THEY
WERE MAKING $23 AN HOUR, 27%
INCREASE. STILL NOT GREAT FOR
OUR AREA, BUT A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE. I CHECKED WITH HER
YESTERDAY AND THEY'RE NOW MAKING
$28 AN HOUR STARTING SALARY, BUT
WITH ALSO MUCH BETTER HEALTH
BENEFITS THAT STARTING SALARY
BEFORE BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S,
MUCH BETTER HEALTH BENEFITS.
FIRST EVER RETIREMENT PROGRAM
THAT WE STARTED A FEW YEARS AGO.
FIRST IN THE NATION RETIREMENT
PROGRAM FOR CHILD CARE WORKERS,
AND THEY GET 100% REIMBURSEMENT
FOR A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND IN
SOME CASES, A MASTER'S DEGREE.
SO THIS IS ALLOWING, FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY AREA,
STABILIZATION AND ALLOWING US TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN CHILD CARE
WORKERS AND LET THEM TAKE CARE
OF THE WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED
NOW GOING FORWARD FOR THE
FUTURE. SO I JUST THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR EFFORTS. I COULD GO ON
ON ABOUT EDUCATION AND OTHER
AREAS THAT MY COLLEAGUES LED.
I'M JUST GRATEFUL TO ALL OF YOU
AND PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. I'D LIKE
TO NOW RECOGNIZE OUR PRO TEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
PLAN THAT IS IN FRONT OF US HERE
TODAY. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO OUR BUDGET CHAIR, TO OUR
BUDGET VICE CHAIR, TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND OUR BUDGET
SUB CHAIRS FOR THE AMAZING WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE OVER THE
PAST MANY MONTHS. AND IT'S TAKEN
A LOT OF WORK TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS FAR AND TO BE ABLE TO GET
THIS BUDGET ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE. AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE
HEARD THIS A MILLION TIMES OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS, THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A TOUGH
BUDGET, AND IT WAS, AND THAT'S
WHY IT MAKES THIS BUDGET EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT, BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT EVERY DOLLAR, EVERY DOLLAR
HAD TO BE CAREFULLY CONSIDERED.
AND OUR FOCUS THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE
PROGRESS OF CORE PROGRAMS AND
OUR KIDS AND EDUCATION IN THIS
BUDGET. WE HAVE A RECORD AMOUNT
OF FUNDING FOR OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND KIDS, $1.9 BILLION
MORE THAN WHAT WE SAW IN THE MAY
REVISION. JUST IN 2015, MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA WAS DEAD LAST IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. THE GOLDEN STATE
HAS SOME OF THE MOST PRESTIGIOUS
AND INFLUENTIAL PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN THE WORLD,
WHERE INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL
$258 MILLION FOR THE èC AND 240
MILLION FOR THE CSU SYSTEM. AND
WE'RE RESTORED FULL FUNDING FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
FUND. WE'RE KEEPING CALIFORNIANS
HEALTHY AND WITH GREATER ACCESS
TO MEDICAL AND DENTAL CARE AND
ONE OF THE MOST VISIBLE AND
ACUTE CARE ACUTE CRISES IN OUR
STATE HOMELESSNESS, NO MATTER IF
YOU LIVE IN CRESCENT CITY OR IN
ENCINO, WE'RE FUNDING IMPACTFUL
PROGRAMS THAT WILL HELP BIG
CITIES AND SMALL. WITH OVER $1
BILLION IN THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION GRANT
PROGRAM, WE'RE INVESTING IN
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
RECEIVE $85 MILLION TO CRACK
DOWN ON RETAIL THEFT AND $80
MILLION IN GRANTS TO HELP
NONPROFITS TARGETED WITH HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE AND HATE
CRIMES. AND SO WHAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM OUR ESTEEMED CHAIR OF
BUDGET SUB TWO WILDFIRES.
WILDFIRES IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE IN THIS
STATE. NEARLY 3000 3000 NEW CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS WILL BE HIRED
BETWEEN NOW AND 2029, THANKS TO
THE HARD WORK OF THIS SENATE,
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE COMMITMENT
BY THE GOVERNOR. NOW AGAIN, THIS
HAS BEEN TOUGH AND THERE'S A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO. BUT I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
THE GOLDEN STATE. THERE'S A LOT
SAID ABOUT CALIFORNIA THESE
DAYS, BUT HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
WE ARE SEEING OUR ECONOMY TURN
AROUND. OVER 3.2 MILLION JOBS
RECOVERED SINCE 2020, WHERE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD, THE LARGEST TOURISM YEAR
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY, IS THIS
YEAR. WE'RE NUMBER ONE IN THE
NATION FOR NEW BUSINESS STARTS.
NUMBER ONE IN THE NATION FOR
ACCESS TO VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING. AND WE'RE THE NUMBER
ONE STATE FOR MANUFACTURING,
HIGH TECH AND AGRICULTURE. AND
WE'RE EVEN HOME TO THE OLDEST
KNOWN GIANT SEQUOIA IN THE
WORLD. SO EAT YOUR HEART OUT. SO
WE'RE KEEPING OUR HEADS HELD
HIGH, KNOWING THAT WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE DO BEST FOR NEARLY 40
MILLION FOLKS. AND NO MATTER IF
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT OR A
REPUBLICAN OR NO PARTY
PREFERENCE, YOU'RE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS BUDGET BECAUSE
IT PUTS PEOPLE FIRST. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE, BECAUSE WE'VE
HAD MORE THAN 100 PUBLIC
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS ON THE
BUDGET OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS
BETWEEN THE SENATE AND OUR
PARTNERS AND ASSEMBLY. AND I'M
GOING TO WRAP IT UP RIGHT HERE
AND SAY THIS. THIS BUDGET IS
RESPONSIBLE, METHODICAL, AND
IT'S DESERVING OF OUR SUPPORT.
AND I WANT TO SAY ONE MORE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR
BUDGET CHAIR. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR BUDGET VICE
CHAIR, TO THE BUDGET SUB CHAIRS,
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
OF COURSE, THIS BODY FOR MOVING,
MOVING THIS BUDGET FORWARD WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ANYBO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM. SENATOR
WIENER, PLEASE CLOSE US OUT.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO RATH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY
NO. NGUYEN. NO PORTANTINO. AYES
31. NOS. Ã. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING ON TO
FILE 205. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 109 BY SENATOR
WIENER. AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BUDGET BILL.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 109 IS
A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR, THAT
AMENDS THE 2023 BUDGET ACT TO
REFLECT THE FINAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT REACHED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THE BILL PROVIDES
ALMOST $3 BILLION IN GENERAL
FUND AND ALMOST $600 MILLION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FUNDS FOR THE COMPETITIVE AND
FORMULA TRANSIT PROGRAM AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM.
IT PROVIDES OVER $424 MILLION IN
GRF FOR A VARIETY OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES, CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION, AND OTHER ENERGY
RELATED PROGRAMS AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION. IT
RESTORES $109 MILLION FOR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE, ACCESS AND INFORMATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ DALLY. NÓ. DODD. AYE
DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. NILO. NO. OCHOA. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO. LET'S CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
JONES WHEN. OCHOA PORTANTINO.
AYE. IS 31 NOES. FIVE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM 206. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL 153 BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW, AN ACT RELATING TO
EDUCATION, FINANCE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER.
AYE. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 153 IS THE K
THROUGH 12 EDUCATION OMNIBUS
TRAILER BILL. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE ACTIONS NEEDED TO
PROTECT OVERALL FUNDING FOR PROP
98, AND PROVIDES A 1.07% COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS. IT PROTECTS SCHOOL
STAFF FROM BEING LAID OFF IN THE
UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR, AND IT
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL DRAWDOWNS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD. AYE
LIMON. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. I
MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES. NO
LIMON. AYE NGUYEN. PORTANTINO.
AYES 31. NO. SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM 207. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL 155 BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACT RELATING TO
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 155 IS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL. IT ESTABLISHES THE
REBUILDING, NURSERY, REBUILDING
NURSING INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM TO EXPAND NURSING
PROGRAMS AND PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND TO HELP EDUCATE AND
MAINTAIN THE NEXT GENERATION OF
REGISTERED NURSES. IT DETAILS
THE FINANCING STRUCTURE FOR A
STATEWIDE LEASE REVENUE BOND
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF 13 COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING FACILITIES. THESE
PROJECTS WERE SELECTED AS A PART
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
BUDGET ACT, BUDGET ACTS OF 2022
AND 2023. IT PROVIDES STUDENTS
WHO ARE RETURNING AND CONTINUING
THEIR EDUCATION WITH ADDITIONAL
TIME TO SUBMIT A FREE
APPLICATION FOR FEDERAL STUDENT
AID, MAKING THEM ELIGIBLE FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP IN
2024 2025. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO MIKES UP
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NEILA. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
AYE. DALLI. AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH. AYE. AYES 39. NØ ZERO. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM 208.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 156 BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW, AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC RESOURCES
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SB 156 IS THE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL. IT
INDEFINITELY EXTENDS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION'S ADVENTURE PASS
PROGRAM FOR FOURTH GRADERS. IT
REQUIRES CAL FIRE TO PROVIDE AN
ANNUAL REPORT ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND RESILIENCE WORK. IT
CLARIFIES THE TYPE OF PROJECTS
AND ACTIONS THAT MAY BE EXEMPTED
FROM PAYING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL'S
GENERATION AND HANDLING FEE
PROVIDES DTSC WITH EMERGENCY
RULEMAKING AUTHORITY TO ENSURE
THAT FEE PAYERS ARE PAYING WHAT
THEY OWE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
GOING FORWARD, THE BILL ALLOWS
THE STATE TO COLLECT UNPAID FEES
FROM PRIOR YEARS, BUT DOES NOT
ADD ANY NEW FEES, NOR DOES IT
REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL REPORTING
OR PAYMENT BY ENTITIES THAT HAVE
PAID WHAT THEY OWED IN PRIOR
YEARS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO NO. OKUBO
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI.
NO. GROVE NO. LIMON AYE. NGUYEN
NO. OCHOA. BOG PORTANTINO. AYES
31. NO SEVEN ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
WERE CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 209. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 163 BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW, AN ACT RELATING
TO EARLY LEARNING AND CHILD CARE
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER ALMOST
DONE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. YOU'RE DOING A GREAT
JOB. BY THE WAY, COLLEAGUES, SB
163 IS THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL. IT
CODIFIES THE PLAN TO FUND OVER
200,000 NEW SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE SLOTS ABOVE 2020 LEVELS.
THE FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
REJECTED THE PROPOSAL TO PULL
BACK OVER 11,000 SLOTS OFFERED
THIS SPRING, WITH THOSE SLOTS
RESTORED, WE WILL HAVE FILLED
APPROXIMATELY 130,000 NEW SLOTS.
THE TRAILER BILL LAYS OUT THE
PLAN TO RESUME THE SLOT
EXPANSION AND REACH 200,000
SLOTS BY 2028, 2029, THE BILL
ENACTS A TIMELINE AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW SINGLE
RATE STRUCTURE FOR CHILD CARE
REIMBURSEMENT TO OCCUR AS PART
OF THE 2025 BUDGET. THE TRAILER
BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES THAT THE
CURRENT CHILD CARE RATES,
INCLUSIVE OF INCREASED INCREASES
ACHIEVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET,
ARE A FLOOR FOR FUTURE RATE
SETTING, THE BILL STREAMLINES
THE APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
CURRENT CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
CONTRACTORS TO EXPAND SUBSIDIZED
SLOTS. IT SPECIFIES THAT STATE
PRESCHOOL CLASSROOMS MUST
MAINTAIN 5% OF ENROLLMENT FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. IT
AUTHORIZES THE ENROLLMENT OF TWO
YEAR OLDS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THROUGH
JULY 2027, AND IT MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR SKINNER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS, AND I WANT
TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR
THIS, THE BUDGET COMING TOGETHER
ON THIS ITEM, THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS, WHICH I CHAIR HAS LONG
MADE ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION FOR OUR
CHILDREN. 0 TO 5 A PRIORITY FOR
OVER A DECADE. AND THE LAST
COUPLE OF BUDGETS, WE WERE ABLE
TO SECURE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
IN THAT AND HAVE COME A LONG WAY
TOWARDS ACHIEVING IT. WE HAVE
ALSO COME A LONG WAY IN SECURING
GOOD JOBS FOR OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS, AND WE ARE THE FIRST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY TO NOW
OFFER OUR CHILD CARE WORKERS A
RETIREMENT BENEFIT. SO WITH THIS
BUDGET ITEM, WE ARE ENSURING
THAT GOOD PAY FOR OUR CHILD CARE
WORKERS. WE ARE ENSURING THAT
FAMILIES THAT NEED SOME HELP TO
PAY FOR THAT CHILD CARE, GET
THOSE SUBSIDIZED SLOTS, AND THAT
OUR PRESCHOOLS AND OTHERS ARE
SUPPORTED APPROPRIATELY. AND
WHILE WE'RE NOT YET AT UNIVERSAL
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION FOR 0
TO 5, WE ARE GETTING CLOSER. AND
WITH THAT, I'M VERY THANKFUL,
APPRECIATIVE AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. NOTHING FURTHER.
SENATOR WIENER, PLEASE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ DODD. AYE. Dð. RUSSO.
AYE EGGMAN. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGH
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH.
AYE RUBIO. SATO NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. WIENER
AYE. WILK SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN. AYE
WHEN? NILO NO OKUBO. PORTANTINO
RUBIO. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WILK NO.
AYES 31. NO. SIX. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE THREE MORE ITEMS ON OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. NUMBER TWO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
210. SENATE BILL 164 BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACT RELATING
TO THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB
164 IS THE STATE GOVERNOR, STATE
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL. THE
BILL INCREASES LICENSING,
EXAMINATION AND VARIOUS OTHER
FEES ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. IT
REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF BROADBAND
AND DIGITAL LITERACY TO
PRIORITIZE LAST MILE CONNECTIONS
TO UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
LOCATIONS. AS PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STATEWIDE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND NETWORK,
AND FOR CALTRANS TO PRIORITIZE
CONSTRUCTION OF MIDDLE MILE
SEGMENTS WITH LAST MILE PROJECT
GRANT AWARDS, IT INCREASES THE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
UTILIZATION REVIEW AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM CURES THAT
INCREASES THAT FEE FROM $9 TO
$15. STARTING APRIL 1ST, 2025.
IN ORDER TO RIGHTSIZE THE COSTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM, IT
REORGANIZES THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH OPR
THROUGH THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS
AND ESTABLISHES THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF SERVICE AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. IT MOVES CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS, AND
THE YOUTH EMPOWERMENT COMMISSION
FROM OPR TO THIS NEW OFFICE. IT
MOVES THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST
PROGRAM AND THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PROGRAM FROM OPR TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IT
MOVES THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE
TO ADVANCE PRECISION MEDICINE TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. IT EXTENDS THE DEADLINE
FOR THE RACIAL EQUITY COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP A RACIAL EQUITY
FRAMEWORK FROM APRIL 1ST, 2025
TO DECEMBER 1ST, 2025 REQUIRES
THE STATE AUDITOR TO CONDUCT AN
AUDIT OF THE COUNTY OF MENDOCINO
THAT INCLUDES AN AUDIT OF ANY
POTENTIAL WASTE, FRAUD, ABUSE
AND MISMANAGEMENT. THE COUNTY'S
ADMINISTRATION OF ELECTIONS IN
2024 AND CONTRACTING AND
PROCUREMENT PROCESSES BY JANUARY
1ST, 2026. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DEL. NÓ DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. ACIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. LIMÓN.
AYE PORTANTINO. AYES 31. NOS.
Ã. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN HOMESTRETCH.
SENATORS. THESE ARE THE LAST TWO
ITEMS. FILE ITEM 211. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 174 BY
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW, AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC RESOURCES AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
WIENER, THE MICROPHONE GAVE UP
ON YOU, SENATOR. THERE WE GO. I
THINK IT'S ON THE OKAY. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I DID WEAR
IT OUT, COLLEAGUES, SB 174 IS
THE RESOURCES SEQUA TRAILER
BILL, IT EXTENDS THE CEQA
EXEMPTION FOR CLIMATE AND
BIODIVERSITY PROJECTS BY FIVE
YEARS TO 2030, IT EXEMPTS THE
WORK PERFORMED UNDER THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX ACT OF
2016 FROM SEQUA, AND IT
APPROPRIATES A TOTAL OF $700
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
SPREAD OVER THREE FISCAL YEARS
TO FUND THE ACQUISITION, DESIGN,
CONSTRUCTION AND EQUIPPING OF
PROJECTS AUTHORIZED BY THE ANNEX
ACT AND REQUIRES THE AMOUNT
APPROPRIATED IN EACH FISCAL YEAR
TO BE TRANSFERRED TO THE STATE
PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE FUND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
ACIERTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE WILK. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN AYE.
GROVE AYE. PORTANTINO EYES 32.
NO. SEVEN ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. HERE WE GO FOR
ITEM 212. LAST ITEM. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. FOR ITEM 212. THEY
DON'T WANT US TO LEAVE.
SENATORS, GIVE US A MINUTE. JUST
ONE. JUST ONE ITEM. SENATE BILL
175 BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AND ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR WIENER, YOUR LAST
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 175 IS
THE TAXATION TRAILER BILL, THE
BILL WAS, SB 167, WAS PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE ON JUNE 13TH OF
THIS YEAR AND LIMITED TAX
CREDITS FOR TAXABLE YEARS 20,
24, 25 AND 26. SB 167 FURTHER
INCLUDED INTENT LANGUAGE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT LEGISLATION
ALLOWING ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS TO
RECEIVE A REFUND OF THE CREDITS
THEY WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE USED
TO REDUCE TAX LIABILITY DURING
THE LIMITATION TIME PERIOD. THIS
BILL SPECIFIES THE DETAILS OF
TAX CREDIT REFUNDABILITY
RELATING TO THE BUSINESS TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION, THEREBY
FULFILLING THE COMMITMENT THAT
WE MADE IN SB 167. SPECIFICALLY,
THE BILL ALLOWS TAXPAYERS
SUBJECT TO THE BUSINESS TAX
CREDIT LIMITATION TO ELECT TO
CONVERT THE AMOUNT OF UNUSED
ALLOWABLE TAX CREDITS IN THE 24,
25, 26 TAXABLE YEARS TO
REFUNDABLE CREDITS THAT CAN BE
CLAIMED OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD
BEGINNING THE THIRD TAXABLE YEAR
AFTER THE ELECTION IS MADE.
INCLUDE. IT INCLUDES A TRIGGER
TO ALLOW THE NOL SUSPENSION AND
TAX CREDIT LIMITATION TO BE
TURNED OFF THROUGH THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. IF THE STATE HAS
SUFFICIENT REVENUES AND IT MAKES
A VARIETY OF OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE NO. FINAL THOUGHTS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. JUST KIDDING.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE NOW HURTADO I
JONES NO. LAIRD I LIMON I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NILO NGUYEN. NO
NILO OKOBO PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROTH I RUBIO. SATO. NO SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO, GILL. NILO
OCHOA. BOGH PORTANTINO. RUBIO I.
SECRETARY, ONE MORE TIME, PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GILL, NILO. OCHOA.
BORG PORTANTINO. OCHOA. BOGH. NO
AYES 30. NO. SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE
GOING TO PAUSE.
SENATORS. EARLY CHRISTMAS GIFT.
YOU ARE GETTING AN HOUR AND A
HALF BACK OF YOUR TIME. IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE. FANTASTIC WORK. AND AS A
PARTING GIFT, WE'LL BE HERE TILL
3:00 TOMORROW, SO WE'LL JUST A
REMINDER, MEMBERS, WE'LL HAVE
VOTES TOMORROW. STARTING AROUND
9 A.M. ISH. GOING TO ABOUT 3
P.M. ISH, AND GREATLY APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE WORK. AND JUST ONE
LAST TIME. AND I DON'T MEAN TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THIS, BUT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU. I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES AT TIMES
BETWEEN THE MEMBERS WHO ARE ON
THIS FLOOR, BUT ONE THING THAT
UNITES US IS PUTTING THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA FIRST. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN TO OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE, OUR BUDGET
CHAIR, OUR VICE CHAIR, AND CAN
WE PLEASE GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO OUR BUDGET STAFF,
BOTH REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS? THANK YOU FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK. WE ARE TRULY
APPRECIATIVE. NEXT FLOOR SESSION
WILL BE THURSDAY, JUNE 20TH,
JUNE 27TH AT 9 A.M. ISH. THE
SENATE IS NOW ADJOURNED. WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY, JUNE 27TH AT
9 A.M.